cheese butter is the delicious Gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter I love this
stuff perfect on bread Bagel sandwiches
veggies and more and you'll get twenty
percent off when you go to
cheesebutta.com Pacman the link is down
below let's start today talking about
food shortages there is a new storyline
a new narrative claims that food
shortages are imminent in the United
States and that there's going to be no
food the shelves will be bare as the
failed former president Donald Trump
would often like to say Joe Biden even
said it this was about three weeks ago
and the context was the Russian invasion
of Ukraine and the related sanctions and
responses here's Joe Biden three weeks
ago nothing more to report with regard
to food Shores yes we did we talk about
food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real the
price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon Russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
European countries in our country as
well so on the other hand we also have
kind of the more hyperbolic
fear-based kind of reactionary claims
here's one example from a right-wing
host Dan bongino who had a segment
called the devastating food crisis is
coming please prepare now and the
Preppers loving this the food crisis
coming up it's a topic we've covered on
the show and the radio show often right
there's a devastating food crisis coming
ladies and gentlemen and you darn well
better be prepared listen I care about
you a lot I'm not kidding I love the
audience it's why there's an email on
our website that's why I leave the
Facebook page open for your messages
right I am here for you I am one of you
I came from you I'm a middle class kid
who had a middle class job with a middle
class life okay so anyway
without his full biography the point is
the right is increasingly saying food
shortages are coming many of the people
predicting the food shortages will also
sell you food packaged food bonus
buckets there's a lot of comments if you
look at the Dan bongino piece where
people sing from my Bible study group we
can get food and all of this different
stuff so let's talk it through is it
possible that we could have a food
shortage of course of course there have
been food shortages in history and they
are possible the first step in really
thinking critically about this is what
do we mean by a food shortage because
there are some people who seem to think
that if food shortages my favorite
orange juice wasn't available I had to
get pulp instead of no pulp or I like
turkey bacon but there was no turkey
bacon so I had to consider regular bacon
or plant-based bacon that's not really a
food shortage now I'm gonna get to that
which is the products we expect just
aren't there okay we're going to talk
about that in a moment but a food
shortage when we talk about it
economically is there's not enough
energy or there's close to not enough
energy meaning calories available for
the proper nutrition of a population and
I would even go further
I would say there's not enough calories
available from a reasonably diverse set
of foods what I mean by that is Imagine
That in order to meet our caloric needs
everybody had to be drinking corn syrup
like okay we'd be getting our calories
but I would still consider that to be a
food shortage because it's not a calorie
shortage but it's definitely a shortage
of a reasonably diverse diet so the
first question is is an actual shortage
based on that softer definition not even
going to be able to really get the food
groups we need is that likely this year
based on the evidence we have and the
answer is no it's hard to say more but
there's not going to be a food group
calorie deficit there's going to be
enough meat
there's going to be enough Dairy there's
going to be enough produce there will be
enough grains
um we're not going to actually have a
shortage of calories from any particular
food group now
might there be a situation where in
Portland Oregon
there's no chicken breast for a day at
the local store and you've got to get
chicken thigh yeah that that could
happen those things anecdotally are
happening and we'll talk about why in a
moment but my store was out of a
particular cookie and so I had to get
the Milano you know I mean most of us
aren't Savages so we get dark chocolate
you might have to get the milk chocolate
I know it's not good it's ugly I get it
it's ugly I I you know I'm for dark
chocolate as much as the next guy but uh
that's not really a food shortage right
the shelves aren't bare now let's get
into what might happen just so we all
know and we're aware and we're prepared
is it possible that specific products
might ebb and flow in their supply
so that you might have to choose
something different that you're used to
getting yeah that is possible and that's
definitely different than what most of
us in the United States are used to the
war in Ukraine is likely to disrupt
wheat and sunflower seed oil and
sunflower seed oil is actually in a lot
of foods that many of us buy but it's
more likely to be disruptive to
countries other than the United States
the U.S is actually a big wheat exporter
and producer poorer Nations that demand
that rely more heavily on on Imports of
wheat are going to be more at risk for
example so like the wheat issue will hit
Egypt Indonesia Bangladesh Pakistan
turkey some other countries there will
likely not be
shortages but there might be some
limited availability of meat Dairy and
some animal products there might also be
a shortage of a lack of availability I
think is the word I should say of some
plant-based vegan proteins those for two
reasons one there are some people who if
they don't see the meat that they want
they might try the plant-based
alternative the plant-based alternatives
are also highly processed foods and the
supply chain can't be accelerated that
easily a lot of those processed items
you you can't easily adjust the supply
chain quickly it can take six to nine
months so you might see that so we might
see slight sporadic Regional temporary
lack of availability of certain products
now what could cause the appearance of
an actual shortage
Panic buying like we saw early in the
pandemic and in that case you know is it
really a shortage if a ton of people are
pre-purchasing a Year's worth of
whatever and what I mean by that is
think back to the so-called toilet paper
shortage there was no toilet paper on
the shelves that's true but the reason
was that a ton of people bought a year's
supply so they're good now for a year
and as we saw once the supply
normalized we had fewer people buying
the toilet paper because they
pre-purchased it in the first month of
the pandemic so that was an apparent
shortage it wasn't a real shortage it's
also by the way interesting how a lot of
the producers of some of these Foods
Tyson Purdue for example in poultry
they've had record profits above and
beyond the rate of inflation so it's not
just inflation that's driving their
profit at a time of allegedly
significantly higher costs to them so
I'm not ready to say that there is price
gouging going on but it is interesting
that Prof fit margins remain at record
highs despite supposedly higher costs
and inflation and all of that so we're
going to follow it that's the best
assessment we have right now based on
the information that we have
there is a very disturbing video of
police aggressively arresting an
eight-year-old for allegedly stealing a
bag of potato chips in Syracuse New York
now originally this story was reported
as a 10 year old boy that was being
really treated like an adult for
allegedly stealing a bag of potato chips
we have since learned that this is
actually as of right now believed to be
an eight-year-old could that also be
wrong maybe but as far as we know right
now this is an eight-year-old I'm gonna
play the video the video is disturbing
not in a gory sense it's just disturbing
in terms of how these police officers
are treating this kid let's take a look
[Music]
what's going on there you're stealing
stuff if he breaks into your house he
steal something
y'all treat me like an old cold blooded
killer keep walking dude you don't even
know what you're saying I know what I
just came up and see I just came up and
see okay what did you see I see y'all
snatching them off the bike like your
[ __ ] grown ass man
all right now the the kid is black and
um we I mean we we have to consider the
racial component here and I I I told the
story on our live stream yesterday when
I was I think I was like 10 or 11.
and my little brother was eight or nine
we went grocery shopping and we get home
and I remember this like it was
yesterday because it was so notable to
me we got home
and my brother pulls out a king-size
Snickers bar not even the normal size
this is the big boy you know it's like
uh it it it's like a huge steel rod you
know the the king-size Snickers
and my mom said to my brother sir where
did you get that now she didn't call him
sir
um she said where where'd you get that
and he says the grocery store and what
do you mean where was it it was at the
checkout you know I I got it
and my mom explained no no we we can't
do that that's stealing you can't do
that and to teach the lesson
uh they went back to the grocery store
and they said
he took this and we didn't pay for it so
we're coming back to return it and you
know management was like oh thank you so
much for being honest you know what for
your honesty go ahead and keep it and I
think my mom insisted on paying for it
then you know to teach a lesson and
whatever and it was really notable and
it sticks out in my mind and it was like
this is the way that things are supposed
to be done
imagine if police were involved for the
for the Snickers it would it would just
be outrageous it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be Justice it wouldn't be educational it
wouldn't be something that would point
my brother in the right direction when
it comes to a place I mean there's just
no upside to handling it in that way now
my brother wasn't black at the time he's
still not black in fact some people
might be shocked that he's still not
black so obviously we have this question
of the racial component would this would
this situation have been handled the
same way if a white kid had stole you
know a Jelly Bean or whatever the case
may be
we can't say because they're two
different situations but it certainly
doesn't look good we've now heard from
the
um oh no this is the wrong story we've
now heard from the mayor of Syracuse who
weighed in this is Mayor Ben Walsh and
said that he was concerned when he saw a
boy put in the back of a cruiser after
allegedly stealing a bag of chips
um and the mayor said from what he saw
the boy wasn't placed in handcuffs the
officer knew the child from prior
interactions and explained to him he was
being taken home the officers returned
the child to his family and discussed
the incident before leaving without
filing any charges so it seems as though
the the perspective they're taking is
sort of like well listen he wasn't
cuffed he wasn't arrested he wasn't
charged he was just basically taken home
and explained you know he was it was
explained to him why what he did was
wrong but the manhandling is absolutely
absurd even the placing in the back of
the police car I mean listen again when
I was growing up when an officer got
involved in one of these let me help
right let me be the positive influence
you put the kid in the front right and
now you could say well but sometimes the
police cars have the laptops in the
front the entire handling is wow this is
a criminal and unfortunately this is
exactly the type of thing that can point
people kids to adversarial perspectives
with police it can can point them in the
direction of repeating these actions in
the future so it's all horrible now
meanwhile
earlier in the week I mentioned there
was a shooting in Syracuse and it's not
like there's a shortage of other stuff
police can be involved in there were
like four officers involved at least
with this eight-year-old kid uh we now
have learned that a Syracuse man has
been arrested in that Armory Square
shooting that I told you about from over
the weekend and so it's not even a case
of like there's nothing else to do in
Syracuse it's not a direct line where
like if these four officers weren't you
know taking this kid uh um into custody
or whatever
um that they would have been involved in
solving or preventing that shooting okay
I get that but there is not a sort of
there's nothing for police to be doing
in Syracuse sort of situation so let me
know your thoughts many people outraged
over this some saying the police handled
it fine that's not my perspective but I
would love to hear from you you can find
me on Twitter at dpacman
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries my girlfriend and
I have been using the Curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop I can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than Netflix Hulu
or Amazon on curiosity stream I'm always
finding documentaries by the world's
best filmmakers stuff you can't find on
other streaming services last month they
added a ton of awesome new titles to the
library I just finished watching
becoming Martian about the future of the
human species and its possible path
through Mars but there's documentaries
on every topic imaginable science nature
history politics if you love
documentaries the way I do you are not
going to find a better source of brand
new award-winning docs anywhere else
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 off which means you can subscribe for
just 15 bucks a year not a big price tag
for the hours and hours of enjoyment I
know you will get from curiositystream
just go to curiositystream.com
pacman25 the link is underneath this
video
we're now learning about the next phase
of obstruction of the house committee
investigating the January 6 Trump riots
and it just doesn't stop every week we
learn about something like this the new
one is that John Eastman that's the
lawyer who wrote the memo explaining how
maybe Mike Pence could overturn the
election results that guy John Eastman
is now blocking 3200 trump-related
documents from the house January 6th
committee as reported by CNN meanwhile
Business Insider is reporting that
Eastman is refusing to hand over 37
000 pages of emails to the capital Riot
committee so let's go through what's
going on John Eastman a far-right lawyer
for then president Donald Trump who
wanted to block his electoral loss in
2020 is withholding about 3 200
documents from the house select
committee investigating the riots
Eastman previously was ordered by the
court to turn over 101 documents after
claiming some were confidential legal
community occasions since he's continued
to work through a hundred thousand pages
of emails from his Chapman University
account that the house committee wants
at this time Eastman is arguing that the
thousands of documents comprising about
37 36 000 pages should stay confidential
federal judge David Carter may continue
to weigh whether he can keep those pages
Secret
uh meanwhile John Eastman is refusing to
hand over 37 000 pages of emails to the
committee he says they're shielded by
attorney-client privilege a judge is
weighing the argument Eastman is known
for writing a memo detailing how Trump
could overturn the 2020 election uh I
think at this point we should never
again be subjected to a single word
about Hillary's emails we should never
again be held and brutally pummeled with
the idea that Democrats don't handle
data correctly they don't handle
information correctly or any of it now I
will be subjected to that you will be
subjected to that we all are going to be
subjected to that but we really
shouldn't have to and the strategy at
this point is abundantly clear they are
trying to run the clock out on the
January 6th investigation and they
indeed May succeed that's the saddest
part I have read a bunch of legal
opinions about the strategy
and whether it's a moral strategy or not
whether it is ultimately legal that they
can just refuse to turn stuff over by
the time it's adjudicated Republicans
may have control of the house and this
investigation will be dunzo and there's
really not that much that can be done
about it
um that seems to be the strategy because
Republicans have made it very clear if
they take control of the house in
November
and uh and are sworn into that control
in January of 2023 which is how it works
this investigation is over and I believe
they will almost certainly at least
attempt impeachment proceedings of uh
President Joe Biden I don't think they
will go anywhere but I think that they
will attempt it they're telling us
they're going to attempt it many of them
are and I believe them and this is why
they are stalling in this way if they if
the circumstances were different where
there were going to be if there was a
guarantee of not another what is it nine
months of democratic control
but rather two years and nine months as
an example
a lot of these people that are very
clearly just obstructing at this point
in time and spending tons of legal
dollars trying to avoid disclosing
information likely wouldn't be doing it
because that timeline two years and nine
months versus just nine months would
almost certainly lead to a bunch of this
stuff being forced to be turned over to
the January 6 committee because that's
what the last year has shown us uh much
of the many of these challenges to try
to prevent documents from being given
turned over to the January 6 committee
ultimately a judge says you got to give
them the information we've seen it with
Trump we've seen it with others
ultimately uh Kimberly Guilfoyle ends up
in sitting with the committee and
whatever else but at this point they
have nine months and really six and a
half until the election takes place my
instinct is that if indeed Republicans
win in November that period between
November and January I don't know how
much investigation is going to take
place then so in some real sense if we
want to be conservative about it
Democrats have like until October to get
this done that's now five and a half
months away
the running out the clock strategy does
seem to make sense and by the way this
is going to keep happening until there's
actually consequences for it
um why wouldn't they just dig their
heels in and refuse to comply because
Trump's entire presidency was what are
you going to do about it what are you
going to do about it yes I said I was
going to disassociate from my businesses
and I didn't and I made 1.6 billion
while I was president and my kids made
hundreds of millions and Ivanka was
sitting in for my secretary of state at
a meeting and I can't even give you the
full list of stuff and it's been so so
the hell what because there have been no
consequences whatsoever and I will take
it and even step further
I don't even know how much this
committee ultimately matters the
committee of course if they find
evidence of criminality they they can
and they must refer it to the Department
of Justice as of right now there's no
evidence that the department of justice
under Merrick Garland is genuinely
willing to bring charges against any of
these people I'm not saying Joe Biden
should get involved he shouldn't
as I've said many times before Biden
should have no involvement in saying to
the justice department investigate here
find charges here absolutely not but put
Joe Biden take Joe Biden out of this
because he's not even involved there is
no evidence that Merit Garland and his
justice department are really willing to
even consider doing what are admittedly
politically very difficult things when
it comes to the failed former president
and his administration so of course
Republicans are doing what they're doing
why wouldn't they this is absolutely
humiliating video of former Fox News
host Bill O'Reilly this is um you know
I've said before that there's really no
Trend where I've met left-wing media
people and right-wing media people and
there's no hard and fast rule about oh
the lefties are nice and the righties
aren't in fact my experience has been
the exact opposite some of the most uh
file
mean rude people I've met in this
business
our prominent left-wing hosts I'm not
going to name them
um I think the one I've named is Ed
Schultz he he you know he has passed
away and at this point it's sort of
irrelevant but not a nice guy one of the
worst people that I've ever met
everybody else is still alive
most of the right Wingers have been
super nice I mean I don't like his
politics but Mike Huckabee Sean Hannity
I I could go these they're they're nice
people when you meet him in person at
conferences they'll stand around and
chat and and talk shop and all this
different stuff okay but there's there's
nice and rude people on both sides Bill
O'Reilly has a reputation for being
absolutely vile and disgusting I've
never met the guy we now have a viral
video of Bill O'Reilly at a JetBlue
terminal at JFK airport Bill O'Reilly
was trying to get to Turks and Caicos
for his vacation and the flight was late
the flight was late and Bill O'Reilly
absolutely loses it and starts
threatening a JetBlue gate agent who has
no say whatsoever about when flights
come and go uh with his job starts
threatening you're going to lose your
job here is Bill O'Reilly people who are
watching might notice Bill O'Reilly is
looking extremely gaunt uh I I knew he
was tall he looks so skinny that it
almost looks unhealthy that's an aside
and here he is threatening the JetBlue
worker with his job all captured on
camera
and by the way can I just say
this was when the mask requirement was
still in place at airports why does he
have to pull the mask down to talk I
just I don't understand when people do
this but okay that's not for me to
understand
[Music]
I want to see a manager
so yeah here Bill Bill O'Reilly's asking
for the manager
three hours a week
what are you gonna do it's three hours
late the gate agent doesn't control that
you're gonna
you're gonna find out then he does the
thing where he looks really closely at
the guy's name tag
now Bill O'Reilly who's much taller than
the employee starts leaning in
intimidating this is the most
humiliating Behavior
you're threatening with violence the
employee now says
please get that information
you're gonna lose your job
okay
we'll see
and off goes Bill O'Reilly lumbering
away
um you know one of the things I I am
nowhere near as well known as uh as Bill
O'Reilly but the number of people that
come up to me in public and say hello
has made me realize I always need to be
on my best behavior I can't be on a
phone yelling at anybody if I'm at the
airport I'm going to be extremely polite
if I'm talking to my girlfriend or
whatever I'm going to make sure that
everything always looks as if everything
is going swimmingly and beautifully no
matter what is going on uh because this
is exactly what I want to avoid and the
the the the yelling at employees and
threatening their jobs particularly when
don't we all know how how uh Aviation
works at this point in time I once had a
situation where I had a flight delayed
seven hours out of a very small airport
where there was there was that's the one
flight and it was delayed because of
weather I was miserable but what I'm
gonna do this the person at the airport
doesn't handle the flight coming and
going and it's just an absolutely
humiliating situation to be caught in
and it is not a surprise sometimes
rumors are true sometimes rumors are not
true Bill O'Reilly widely known as a
prick for lack of a better term and
coming off exactly that way and one of
the things that for me is particularly
bothersome
is
when individuals that are in that are
wealthier and in privileged positions
um are really talking down to service
workers I see it more often in
restaurants where sometimes I will be
with people who are not particularly
mean people
and they just don't treat service
workers well they don't treat the wait
staff well and it makes me genuinely
uncomfortable I go out of my way to try
to treat people well and Bill O'Reilly
clearly doing the opposite here not a
surprise coincides perfectly with what
we thought we knew about Bill O'Reilly
we'll have the clip on our Instagram at
davidpackman show if you've just been
listening today we'll take a quick break
and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
we're going to continue our
conversations with 2022 midterm
candidates today we will be speaking
with J.R Majewski who's a republican
candidate for congress hoping to
represent Ohio's Ninth District uh Jr
it's really great to have you on today
thanks Dave good pleasure to be here sir
I appreciate it so uh so why are you
running what what led you to run
well
um you know I've lived in the Ninth
District for
um pretty much my entire life born and
raised here and um I've become more and
more active in the community and uh you
know I decided that uh with with Marcy
captor being at you know having served
office for 40 years and
um you know just the way the country I
think is going at this time I think that
uh it's time it was time for someone
like me to jump in the race and someone
that's actually born here and and that
was raised here understands the district
you know grew up and and lived through
all the trials and tribulations at the
district has to offer and someone who
served the country I think that uh you
know I could be a uh an asset to all the
people that live here what things would
you say are not going in the right
direction in the district
um representation I think is is is one
thing
um you know if you if you go across
District nine and talk to folks
regardless of their political
affiliation
um they find uh many people don't even
know who Mercy is and you know having
been in office for 40 years I find that
troubling
um you know this secondly we're we're
becoming more and more of a polarized
um nation and uh I think getting back
into the practice of engaging in healthy
political discourse is missing and uh
you know that's something that that I've
always been about and um you know I I
really think that we need someone to
bring that behavior and that mindset
into uh the leadership position of of
Representative for for this district one
of the things that your I believe it's
your communications director it was your
Communications contact that we were in
touch with said was that you're a
constitutional Warrior and you want to
take the country back can you talk about
who do you want to take it back from
I think it needs to be take taken back
from The Establishment from from those
that were elected by the people to
fulfill you know various roles of office
but yeah I think the people
um are the general consensus in my
opinion is that the people feel as if
the government and our elected
representatives are extremely
indifferent from what our expectations
were when we voted them into office can
you give an example of that in other
words what would be who would be an
individual where we would say the
expectation was a and here's B which is
what they're actually doing and we don't
like it
um I would say
example a would be
um Marcy campner you would expect if you
made a phone call to your representative
that you would get contacted and be
contacted and responded to within a
reasonable amount of time and
um I've I've very rarely have met anyone
that can describe to me a situation
where they've called and they've got a
response within 72 48 out 48 72 hours I
mean some folks do not even get
responded back to so one of your big
things would be I'm hearing you say I
think I'm hearing you say you would set
up a system to respond to constituents
more quickly absolutely one of my
campaign commitments actually my first
one is that you know I hold a town hall
in every County within the district that
I represent at least once a quarter
when it comes to the Constitutional
piece of some of the material that we
got from you are there parts of the
Constitution that you believe aren't
currently being followed
yeah I think free speech is being
trampled on right now on you know from
from various Outlets um
mostly from what I what I see is social
media and big Tech okay um I can give
examples of that now just to be clear Jr
so our audience understands
I when I said the Constitution when you
say Free Speech am I right to understand
that you mean the First Amendment to the
Constitution yeah our first amendment
okay correct now the institutions you
mentioned aren't governmental
institutions and the First Amendment
only applies to government so in what
way would that apply to Big Tech or
social media well generally speaking I
think we have a right to free speech and
when we have institutions that
um are are meant to and intended to be a
a forum where public discourse can can
um
take place and you have arbitrary
decision makers that decide what is good
and what is bad I think that's that that
is in my opinion uh an assault against
the our first amendment rights so let's
dig into that because I think this is
such a meaty issue where there's so much
to discuss will will you concede that
the First Amendment only applies to
government like Twitter has nothing that
Twitter is not governed by the first
amendment I hear you saying maybe you
would like it to be but do you agree
that as far as the law is today Twitter
and the First Amendment are not
intertwined in any way
I would say that
I'm not I wouldn't be prepared to answer
that now in the manner which I would
like I like to look into things a little
bit more
um but I would say that the general you
know perceptions reality right and and
um
at this day and age I feel as if there
is
um again I think when I post this
something on on Facebook and it gets
taken down and it's labeled as promoting
hate speech when I'm just posting a
picture of a meme of someone there's no
violence and it's just someone's face
okay I I don't I don't comprehend how
that is
um you know promoting violence or it's
to me so that sounds like that's your
opinion about a meme but I guess so we
can establish a set of facts on which we
can then talk about this Facebook having
terms of service has nothing to do with
the First Amendment to the Constitution
and government abridging speech right
I can agree with that you can agree with
that so it sounds like you don't like
the way some social media companies are
enforcing terms of service is that fair
right yeah that's fair
in general as a conservative
constitutional conservative do you favor
more or less business regulation
um less I would think but it it's all
it's all circumstantial I mean you know
there has to be some regulations not all
of our businesses are automatically
ethical and and principally driven so
100 100 but in general you tend to favor
letting businesses do what they want to
do if as long as it's not against the
law maybe is that fair
to a degree but I mean you know if they
some some uh
um you know some some businesses work
under the auspices of uh purchase
agreements that's not necessarily the
law or Labor Relations agreement so I
mean you know there's just a fine line
of of being ethical and and uh you know
meaning excuse me meeting their their
responsibilities regardless of you know
where that where that responsibility
stems from 100 fair I'm with you all the
way as applied oh yeah go ahead I'm
actually more of a Libertarian
um oh even so even more interesting then
so as a Libertarian would you agree that
forcing a private company like Twitter
or Facebook to have to publish Your Meme
would be extremely authoritarian
regulation of businesses
I mean I can agree I can I can I can say
yes but I mean it's all it's all based
on context you know or when when
I mean there's nothing that explicitly
limits my ability to
um
post that Meme because there was no
violation of their terms of services I
can so yeah no it sounds like you
disagree with the enforcement but you're
not actually suggesting the government
Force Facebook to have to let you
publish it you just disagree with their
choice right but I think I think the you
know the arbitration needs to be taken
out of the picture it needs to be black
and white there needs to be if they're
going to have rules those rules should
be you know uh enforced okay fair yeah
no I I think we might disagree about how
to enforce it but I don't I don't
disagree with you in principle
um what this is just kind of like a gut
check question that I've been asking
candidates that we talk to and
shockingly sometimes they don't they're
not able to answer who's the current
president of the United States chair
Joe Biden okay and is he do you think he
was elected legitimately
I think the election was stolen
personally I know you do I think there
were extreme irregularities with with
the election yes in which states
um oh man you got me on the spot
um
I know well I guess let me put it a
different way there's no one state that
uh Biden won that's in question that
would have flipped it to Trump so I
guess what group of states might be part
of it well I mean Georgia had election
irregularities uh Arizona Pennsylvania
Wisconsin
um even here in Ohio we had some okay
and when you say irregularities there's
been claims levied like for example dead
people voted people voted twice you know
all these different things somebody
there were quote massive dumps of
ballots in the middle of the night this
type of thing what specifically do you
think happened like in Georgia for for a
good job and I mentioned Georgia because
Republicans oversaw that and were in
charge of the election what do you think
happened
I mean personally I don't speculate on
those things what I say is that you know
where they're smoking there's fire okay
and I believe that congrats I I believe
that our Congress had an obligation to
um you know put put those concerns of a
lot of American people to rest whether
they were right or wrong uh our
Congressional members have an obligation
and the fact that we want you know we
we've moved forward and um Congress
hasn't put those issues to rest that is
it's it's just uh
it's exacerbated the problem where we
have people on both sides of the aisle
that are that are so polarized I mean
well help me understand putting to rest
because when I do I try to do a fair
hearing right of the claims sure and we
had 63 different state level legal
complaints filed all found to be either
without Merit or to lack standing and we
had a variety of different
investigations take place in different
states there was one in Georgia there
was one in Arizona sometimes it turns
out Joe Biden won by even more what
would satisfy you that would quote put
it to rest as you say
um I an audit a full-on audit of the
states that that have asked for one
um if if you know Arizona claims that
they've had an election irregularities
and they are the the people there are
asking for an audit I believe that you
know our Congress should allow that to
move forward but they didn't not it in
Arizona and Biden got even more votes
okay the Cyber ninjas did the audit was
it was that audit not satisfactory
that's true that's true you're right on
that
um
what about Wisconsin Pennsylvania
yeah I guess the question would be if
there are irregularities why is it that
no courts seem to agree with that even
when it's Trump appointed judges you
know I'm trying to figure it out for
myself yeah but I mean you're somewhat
of putting a slight on its Republican
this Republic I'm not looking at it in
that manner I'm looking at it from the
people okay the people are asking for I
mean it's not a partisan argument it's
if the people believe that the election
was stolen whether if it's they you know
they believe it in their hearts or you
know they're they're out surfing the
internet and they're they're they're
running rampant on on message boards
right we have an object in my opinion we
have an obligation as the government uh
to to to put those
um concerns the rest let's talk a little
bit about foreign policy
Donald Trump was different than many
previous Republicans who were more
neo-conservative like George W bush in
that Trump talked a lot about he's going
to keep us out of Wars as a combat
veteran yourself and as a republican
what was your sense of the kind of
trumpian foreign policy idea of Wars are
bad and I'm going to keep us out of them
I mean I think it's a good idea I think
that
um you know
who wants to have who want I mean what
kind minded kind-hearted
um American wants to to be in a war I
mean you know I think Wars are bad
um they're good for they're good for the
economy in some respects but they're
they're bad for
um our humanitarian efforts across the
world I mean yeah the United States
should not be engaging in in Foreign
Wars I mean diplomacy should be our
go-to at all times
on that note are you pleased with Joe
Biden's handling of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine so far committing to no boots on
the ground and sticking to it as far as
we can see
um yes I mean I I don't believe that we
should be
um engaging you know in a with a
military effort there
um I'm a little bit displeased with the
um the the messaging that's come out in
the turnaround
um you know in talking about having a
no-fly zone
um sending military equipment I mean to
me that that that's something that uh
I mean no one wants to see ukrainians
die but you know Vladimir Putin has made
it very very clear where he stands on
what he would what he would uh perceive
as as a uh direct threat and he did
highlight some of those things and
I don't think we're doing enough from a
diplomatic perspective you want to see
more diplomacy but you're happy that
there we are not engaging on the ground
absolutely Fair one of the people that
endorsed you is Michael Flynn and he has
said in my opinion some really crazy
things lately including that uh there
that that we should be doing coups and a
lot of really aggressive and almost
sometimes like delusional Christian
dominionist sort of stuff is that a
perspective you would bring if you were
elected or is that not really your scene
I I mean it's hard for me to answer that
I know I know I know what you're asking
for yeah but look I I value my
relationship with General Flynn he's
always been a very very respectful guy
to me
um I have not seen
um I would I've not seen or heard what
what you're saying so okay you know I
I think what you see with me is what you
get I wear my cards on my sleeve I
understand the obligations that I have
you know taking this position and
becoming an elected official my job is
to represent the people
um I think Congress has riddled with
ideologists that are looking to you know
further pursue their self-interest
um I'm a guy that's very young in my
career very successful and uh I don't
need to be a representative
um you know financially I'm I'm much
more uh better off continuing my my
career in the nuclear power industry but
you know again I'm gonna bring to the
table eyes ears and uh the fortitude and
willingness to help everyone in my
district regardless of their political
affiliation but you know I'm not I'm not
going to
um you know who I choose to pursue for
endorsements I mean look I gotta win I
got I I I'm in a I'm in a contested
Republican primary uh General Flynn I
consider him a patriot and uh you know I
I I like general fund so you know I mean
as far as the Testament to his character
I I can't speak on it I can just tell
you that when I think of General Flynn I
think of a guy that was a very
successful General uh in our United
States Army and he's always been kind to
me and uh
um you know I haven't heard anything
radical that I could that I could attest
to well I think I'm reading between the
lines a little here J.R and
understanding what you're saying but I'm
glad to send you some some citations uh
I I'm not trying to dodge the question I
got you no I understand the situation
you're in a contested situation I get it
I get it listen I got it
um listen you've been eminently
reasonable in our conversation and I
think this is eye-opening we've been
speaking with J.R Majewski who's running
in Ohio's Ninth District a trump
supporter but also a guy that we can
engage with on a reasonable basis Jr I
really appreciate your time thanks man I
appreciate yours and I would say to your
listeners you know there's so much
polarization out there right now and uh
you know people see me they see the
Trump on they see the name Trump and you
know look we gotta we have to work with
each other we have to talk and you know
this this this one issue lined in the
sand behavior and you know it we are not
as we are Americans at the end of the
day but people even even before that
we're human and you know we have to find
a a a a landscape in which we can all
get back together because this this
country is going down the tubes if if we
continue on the path we're on and it's
going to take both sides of the owl to
work together to get this done I don't
know if that's possible the way things
are going but you know what damn it I'm
gonna try so Jr thank you so much you're
welcome
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show here's an
interesting follow-up on a story from
earlier this year back in January we
covered this guy named Christopher key
who was promoting the drinking of urine
in order to treat or prevent covid and
we talked about it at the time and I
explained to you then that a lot of this
covid quack stuff it's a recycling of
old ideas that have been going around
for a long time urine has been promoted
in the past for treating cancer even
though the Cancer Society says there's
is no evidence at all for therapeutic
use of urine they've talked about using
urine to irrigate the sinuses almost
like a pea neti pot for brushing teeth
applying it directly to the skin as a
skin treatment of some kind and the
origins or the oranges of this urine
therapy thing is the idea that certain
tumor proteins are present in the urine
of cancer patients and the idea is if
you introduce urine into the digestive
tract by drinking it the erroneous
belief is your body will make antibodies
against the tumor proteins and it'll
destroy the cancer that's like one
example now there's no evidence of that
whatsoever it's true that urine can
contain tumor antigens there's no
evidence that drinking it massaging with
it bathing with it cooking with it or
any other urine application is going to
stimulate antibody production in any way
fight cancer treat any symptom or
disease so that was the idea before from
Christopher key was the drinking of
urine he's now moved on to promoting
injecting urine here is a clip of him uh
at least claiming that he's injecting
himself with aged urine you know how
sometimes people will age steaks this is
age urine I'm doing intramuscular I have
your iodine but I'm just going to
sterilize it with my own urine and
and whatnot but talk about the stem
cells right all right so the stem as
this is going on you see him take out a
syringe tells uh
uh pretty much every
every pure DNA cell that will start
replicating yeah
um additional cells for regeneration and
repair I mean everybody's hearing about
regeneration
um repair people are flying to Thailand
to give stem cell injections done over
there yeah so the idea there is that
Christopher key has injected himself
with uh urine and some people wrote to
me saying David he clearly isn't really
injecting himself I don't think it
matters because if people believe it
it's dangerous and this is all from the
same school of thought uh that sometimes
includes Homeopathy sometimes it
includes you know some of these other I
I I'm not going to wrap too much of it
this is what it is okay now this is
extraordinarily dangerous if you you
know the Christopher key said he's
injecting the urine intramuscularly
if you inject urine into a vein it can
get very bad very quickly there's
actually a study called lethal sepsis
and multi-organ failure after accidental
injection of urine in a drug addict then
the story is about a 33 year old drug
addict that injected uh urine because he
kept it in the fridge in case he needed
it for a drug screening and then he
thought it was methadone and injected it
and it went to a vein and was confused
and shivering and had all sorts of
different symptoms sepsis it was crazy
okay so this is all extraordinarily
dangerous and they just don't seem to be
stopping now I genuinely Wonder like are
they really making money with this I
don't know the guy who's interviewing
Christopher key here is Dr Edward group
and he runs some kind of natural healing
thing and
um does he make money promoting urine
therapy I just don't know I don't I
don't know exactly like what the what
the the money piece is now as I've said
before 4. there is one possible
legitimate life-saving use of urine and
it is as follows if you are completely
dehydrated you're without water you're
on the verge of dying there is a short
period during which drinking your own
urine could extend your life just enough
to be rescued or to get to water right
urine is 95 water and it's believed that
drinking your own urine might allow you
to survive an extra day or two it is
strictly speaking safe it replenishes
some lost water but the problem is the
other five percent of urine that's not
water is not something you want a lot of
in your body right you're taking the
stuff that your kidneys have filtered
out and you're putting it back in and
putting it back into your kidneys and
this can cause really bad symptoms and
long-term problems but if there's
anything that in the urine therapy world
would we would say is sort of legit it
would be you might extend a deadly
situation with no water by a day or two
and that's basically it absolutely
horrifying stuff uh continuing our covid
quack cures treatments and whatever uh
part of the show
um I'm going to play a clip for you
unfortunately if someone that was taken
kind of seriously by some early in the
pandemic there is a vac this is a
so-called vaccine expert named Stella
Emanuel and early in the pandemic there
were a bunch of people taking her very
seriously she appeared on the Stu Peters
show this is the guy who thought when he
had a cold not long ago that someone
weaponized a cold and gave it to him he
probably just had covet he's
unvaccinated he brought on Stella
Emanuel
to defend his satanic snake venom
documentary and she says that the world
is filled with demonic clones this is
someone that the right was going to as
an authority on covid earlier in the
pandemic listen to this I saw people
walking on the street and somewhere
human and somewhere over so we're demons
and the human beings didn't realize that
they were walking around with demons so
right now we are in a time where I would
actually say people have been cloned and
they are walking among us if you watch
the movie called they leave they leave
l-i-v-e it was created by John Carpenter
this is the world we're living right now
and the only way we're gonna survive is
if human beings wake up stop all the
crazy factions the devil has put us in
and stop praying and crying out to God
because that is the only way we're gonna
we're gonna suffer now often with these
folks I come to you and I say this is
not a medical doctor
the crazy thing is
Stella Emanuel is a medical doctor she
is as far as I know she is a physician
and a pastor and she was pushing
hydroxychloroquine absent any evidence
she said social distancing and masks
don't work and all of this different
stuff now as a reminder about Stu Peters
he is this radical right-wing
broadcaster he had the cold or a flu or
covid and he said I'm not going to get
tested but I believe that I was targeted
with this someone injected me with it
this is a very very dangerous guy here's
another clip where Stu Peters speaks to
a guy named Brian artists and they claim
covid is a synthesized form of snake
venom that's the snake venom connection
well what about the name Corona right
does it have a Latin definition or a
definition at all so I actually picked
up what's the definition and on
dictionary.com it brings up 13
definitions Corona religiously
ecclesiastically means gold ribbon at
the base of a miter uh-oh and I didn't
know what a miter was so I copied it and
pasted it and then hit images
so this actually could read the Pope's
Venom pandemic whoa it also can read
Crown Corona means Crown also in Latin
terms Corona means Crown visually we see
Kings represented with a crown symbol oh
man so put that together for me king
cobra Venom
it actually guys the virus is the Venom
of a king cobra could read King Cobra
Venom pandemic now just as a reminder
artist is a chiropractor he's not an
infectious disease doctor he's not a
medical doctor he's not a virologist
he's a chiropractor and he believes he
has figured it out these people are
dangerous and unfortunately they have
followers very very sad stuff tragic
really we're continuing this discussion
of whether it's reasonable to go to
someone of a certain identity to ask
questions about that identity how did it
start well last week I got a voicemail
or maybe it was Monday now I don't
remember last week or Monday I got a
voicemail from someone saying hey David
I have some Jewish questions Yiddish
actually what's the schmeckle what's a
shekel and I answer them and then on
Tuesday the Eggman called in and said
David that that's inappropriate that's
anti-semitic it's like going to a black
woman and asking her to touch her hair
and I said I don't think so I think it's
logical that you would go to people that
you believe might have more knowledge
about something than you and you ask
them about it as long as it's being done
in good faith but the Eggman didn't like
that we have a new voicemail caller this
we're going through every identity we
had a Jewish man call in the Eggman to
give his perspective now a gay man
called in to say he welcomes people
asking him questions about homosexuality
take a listen to this
hey David this is Rich from Palm Springs
California and I was just listening to
your piece uh where you played the
Eggman saying that he thought it was
disrespectful to ask you about uh Jewish
languages and sayings and such and I
agree with you I think he's wrong as a
gay man I have no problem answering
questions I find a lot of straight
people have questions about gay
lifestyle and terms and stuff like that
and they're truly curious but they're
not going to sit at home and Google
stuff
um I mean maybe they would but that's
not really an issue and as long as it's
respectful and not just like some
ignorant jerk being an ignorant jerk
yeah so what I think is inappropriate is
once I was at
um once I was at a brunch this was so
awkward I was at a brunch
and
someone upon fine it was like a round
Passover time at some other some other
year around Passover time and completely
unprovoked just on the basis of figuring
out I was Jewish from from uh mentioning
having been at Passover
this woman says to me in a very
antagonistic way can you explain to me
why the U.S government sends money to
Israel
and it's
it's like I'm expected as a Jewish
person to defend the foreign policy of
the United States and it was clearly bad
faith it was clearly antagonistic it's
like going to I don't know is it going
to a Muslim person and saying can you
defend why the U.S sends money to
Pakistan or Egypt or something like that
that's completely bad faith it was a
completely inappropriate question I
don't know I'm not the spokesperson for
that why are you asking me
um but it's different that someone says
hey what is what is what's schmeckle do
you know what schmeckle is I I think
that's okay and I think it is all it is
all context as the caller points out we
have a great bonus show for you today
Ukraine says Russia's offensive in the
donbos has begun in is rapidly
escalating we're going to talk about it
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is trying
to strip Disney of self-governing power
that doesn't sound like letting
businesses do what they want we'll talk
about it and Sarah Palin as we've said
it she's trying a comeback she's running
for a member of the house but she's
running up against the problem which is
that her star power seems to have
dramatically dimmed in her home state of
Alaska can she still win we'll talk
about it all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show how do you get the
bonus show it's very easy you go to
joinpakman.com and you sign up and
instantly you'll be able to listen to
the bonus show
or watch the bonus show whichever is
your preference if you're more an audio
person you can listen if you're more a
video person you can watch you could
also play the video but only listen to
it I don't know why you would do that
but you could sign up at joinpackman.com
we'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors cheese butter is
the delicious Gourmet cheese melt that
blends four indulgent cheeses and
seasoned butter I love this stuff
perfect on bread Bagel sandwiches
veggies and more and you'll get 20 off
when you go to cheesebutta.com Pacman
the link is down below